hi everyone
welcome to week two of machine learning
and causal inference
just to get everyone up to speed last
week
right you had a crash course on machine
learning
just a reminder of what are some of the
widely used methods in machine learning
what people are doing out there i
imagine that for most of you
that is a review or mostly
now is when we get into really the core
of this class
that is how you can use and deploy
a machine learning based methods in
causal analyses
this week um we're going to focus on a
more more of a classical
topic in causal inference estimating
average treatment effects
um i'll say more in just a few slides
about what that means
um and how we can rigorously deploy
off-the-shelf type machine learning
tools for this task
in the upcoming weeks we're going to dig
deeper and look at
some more specialized tasks
including treatment personalization and
look at how we can kind of
develop special
special purpose machine learning methods
for those tasks
so anyways before saying anything else
just of course the core tension of this
class and one that
uh both susan and i have already
emphasized many times uh but it doesn't
hurt
to say once more is right what's machine
learning
about machine learning methods are about
prediction
they're about giving a type of data
understanding
what usually happens in a given
situation
for example you could download
historical weather data
and then based on that data try to
understand
given the conditions you expect there to
be tomorrow
what's the chance that air pollution
levels will be dangerously high
that's prediction but that's not usually
what we care about
in many economic or social science
applications in many applications like
this we care about
causal questions we don't just
understand care about understanding what
would usually happen
in a given type of situation um we want
to understand counter factuals
we want to understand say what would
happen
not only do we think tomorrow might have
high pollution levels
but can we change this by say reducing
the number of cars on the road
we're most interested in interventions
we might take to kind of
improve the situation so this is
obviously a different kind of question
and as we'll see many times in the class
a naive application of machine learning
methods that are designed for prediction
to cause a task can get one and do quite
a bit of trouble
but as we'll also see if done right then
actually
machine learning methods can be usefully
adapted to causal tasks
and can be very helpful so anyways
um having said that um
this week our goal is to understand
how machine learning methods can be
rigorously deployed for the classical
task of average treatment effect
estimation
and um and
with this um the main result
uh we're gonna we're gonna give it
in the fourth part of this
lecture um the main result is going to
be a methodology
based on double robust estimation that
can kind of take as inputs generic black
box type machine learning estimates
and as output give you confidence
intervals
with kind of a limiting normal sampling
distribution
and all the guarantees you'd like
but okay we need to uh work up to it and
so this
this will be done in kind of four
videos the first video um
in this one um i'll introduce the notion
of the average treatment effect
talk about some basics about how we can
think about average treatment effects in
the context of randomized trials
then in part two
i'm going to talk about kind of some
simple
ways you could think about using machine
learning for average treatment effect
estimation
um compare that to kind of classical
regression based methods
and see what's good what's bad what the
limitations are
uh this spoiler i guess this is not
really a spoiler
alert the naive method won't quite work
you'll leave something on the table you
won't get the confidence intervals
of the type you'd want at the naive
method
so we need to do something else um
and here we're gonna start working
towards it
uh part three may be like an aside at
the time
i'm gonna introduce propensity score
methods
um and kind of
an estimation uh we'll get built around
that
but by the time we'll get to part four
you'll see that this was not an aside
um that kind of state-of-the-art way of
incorporating machine learning methods
into the average treatment effect
estimation world
kind of combines the naive approach with
um insights uh from propensity score
based methods
um that's going to take us to um what's
called the
double double robust methods and
out of all the methods i'm going to talk
about today that's the one i
recommend um you you didn't practice
and that's one i also use often in my
own research
all right so that's the outline and now
we're in part one
so what's the average treatment effect
um here's the definition
um i should emphasize
um again like we mentioned in them in
the intro video
when it comes to defining core notions
um from causal inference we're going to
move quite fast in this class
so if you want more background on these
notions
it may make sense to say read some kind
of
introductory econometrics resources
including some of the ones we've listed
on the syllabus
so okay um for all of today i'm going to
work
in terms of this classical statistical
setup
we have n units and independently
sampled units
and for each unit we observe
a feature vector that's kind of
background information
about who you are a response why
that's the outcome the thing we usually
want to improve uh
using a treatment and then a binary
treatment it's zero or one
zero if you didn't get treated or if
you've got assigned control
and one if you got treated
so this is a standard kaggle setup
and then in order to talk about
causality
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to posit
the existence of these quantities y i 0
y i 1. these are called potential
outcomes
and the way to interpret these
quantities is that
y i zero measures the outcome you would
have observed
for the iv unit had they received
control and why i won
is the outcome you would have received
for the observed for the iq type unit
had they received treatment then of
course the outcome you actually observe
why i is the potential outcome
uh corresponding to the value
wi of the treatment that you actually
received
why are potential outcomes useful it's
because they
enable you to kind of very directly
define a causal effect
the causal effect of the treatment is
the difference in potential outcomes
it's for the eighth unit the effect of
the treatment
is just the difference between what
would have happened to the height unit
with the treatment versus without so
this is
the treatment effect for the ice unit
and
a lot of causal imprints is
going to be trying to say something
about these differences in potential
outcomes
now today we're going to kind of
focus on one specific question you can
ask in terms of these potential outcomes
and that is what is the average
treatment effect
or what is the average
difference in potential outcomes if the
effect the causal effect of the
treatment on the ice unit
was y i one minus y i zero then here's
the thing we're calling tau
the average treatment effect is the
average
across the sampling uh distribution on
of these
individual treatment effects
um the and and the average treatment
effect
is not surprisingly often considered
kind of a burst very helpful
summary measure of the effectiveness of
a treatment
um in some population
so why is this
problem not completely trivial well
taking averages is not that hard
we know how to do that um and
here the difficulty of course is that
you have a missing data problem
for each unit uh the treatment effect
for the the individual treatment effect
of the height unit y i 1 minus y i 0
is defined as the outcome you would have
gotten if you are treated minus the
outcome you would have gotten if you
weren't
that's the difference of two things but
of course you only ever get to observe
one of these two things
either you're treated in which case you
observe the treated potential outcome
or your control in which case you
observe the control potential outcome
but you never get to observe both
so you have this fundamental missingness
issue
um that's what makes this problem not
trivial
on the other hand for it to be
interesting it also needs to be possible
and it turns out that can given the
right methods estimating average
treatment effects is
tractable
so where i want to work
uh towards uh like i said earlier uh
this week is getting to a point where
we have kind of more complicated types
of data and we can kind of bring machine
learning tools to the table
uh to uh kind of
enable flexible and robust estimation of
average treatment effects
in quite a bit of generality
but just as a warm-up let's talk about
the simplest case in which you can
estimate an average treatment effect
and how that works out and of course the
simplest case for doing causal influence
is the randomized trial
we say that you're in a randomized trial
uh
if the treatment assignment is
randomized
that is there are some people who get
treated
some people will get the control
assignment
and it's really who gets treated or
control
is chosen completely at random uh
there's kind of no association between
the potential outcomes
of a unit and the treatment um
qualitatively you could think that it's
a randomized trial
if for every person you flip the coin
the flying coin came out of heads uh you
um assign them to treatment otherwise
you assign them to control
and okay why do we like randomized
trials
um it's well here's kind of
a very short um derivation
which shows that essentially the average
treatment effect
that is the average difference between
the kind of treated potential outcome
and the control potential outcome
um this thing here uh can be expressed
as in this other way
that is the the expected value of the
outcome for the treated units
minus the expected value of the outcome
for the controls
and of course this thing here is easy to
estimate
this is you could just kind of literally
end the randomized trial take the
average
of the ys of the treated units and this
for the controls
so this kind of immediately suggests an
estimator that you could use
for the average treatment effect of
course the important difference here is
that
here we define expectations in terms of
potential outcomes
potential outcomes are not always
observed so we have a missing data
problem
down here we have a conditional
expectation
but in terms of yi's that is kind of
actual observables
there's no problem in estimating the
average of y
conditional on w equals one so this we
can just read out from the data
and there's no problem and
really the key step in this derivation
uh here was this first line
where we argued that
the average of the treated potential
outcome
over the whole sample is the same as the
average of the treated potential outcome
conditional on wi equals one and this
follows from this
this randomization statement um
because treatment is randomized
conditioning on treatment
uh doesn't change um the expectation
um so so this is this is safe
uh then in the second line uh here uh we
went from
the expectation of the treated potential
outcome conditional on being treated to
just the expectation of the outcome uh
being treated
this is kind of more mechanistic kind of
we already agreed that when you're
treated
the thing you observe is the treated
potential outcome so this is kind of
a more topological consequence of the
definition
we've set up but so what does this mean
it means that even though there's this
fundamental missingness problem in
causal inference
you have treated and control potential
outcomes causal effects
are defined in terms of differences of
the things of things you can only ever
observe one of
then it's actually possible to estimate
an average treatment effect using a
randomized trial
that is a data set
where our treatment was generated
uniformly at random
all right so just to kind of illustrate
this in terms of a kind of a
a simple example suppose again that we
wanted to understand
the effect of driving restrictions on
air quality
so what i'm showing in this uh
slide is essentially oracle data
that kind of an omniscient uh
statistician could hope to have every
day
you have y i zero the pollution levels
you would have gotten that day if there
were no uh restrictions on traffic
why i won um another potential outcome
that is the pollution levels you would
have gotten with the traffic reduction
and then this tau i that is the effect
of the traffic reductions on pollution
that day here i made a plot
of the potential outcomes y zero and y i
one
you see that there's it's there's very
strong correlation between y and zero
and y i one
that is most days pollution was what it
was going to be
um and kind of the traffic um um
restrictions only had a kind of second
order effect
but at the same time you also see that y
i one
is typically smaller than y i zero the
data kind of lives
below the diagonal um and this means
that kind of
the traffic reductions did help other
restrictions did help reduce
uh pollution a little bit and
if you take the averages of all these
then what this says is the average
treatment effect
that is the average daily effect of the
traffic restrictions
is here uh negative 10 in the units of
the problem
if we had access to this whole table
getting this negative 10
just averaging the tax would be very
easy but of course this isn't what real
data looks like
and and real data even if you had the
kind of
best data you could hope for you have a
randomized trial
then every day you flip a coin and
depending on how that coin comes out
you either observe y i zero the control
potential outcome
or you observe y i1 the treated
you don't get to observe both and so
in particular your problem is that you
never observe tau eyes
so you might be wondering how can i
estimate the average of the tau
eyes if i never get to observe a
single tau i but this is kind of
like the theorem and we just saw earlier
uh you get an unbiased estimate for taoi
by taking the average of
the outcomes on days where you got
treated minus the average of the outcome
on days where you got control
and then this gives you an average
treatment effect estimate
of minus 10 here
all right this is how it works
randomized trials are very nice
um not much
need for kind of you can do most things
you want in randomized trials
at least in terms of estimating average
treatment effects without using any very
sophisticated methods
but okay we're not always in randomized
trials and then
we need to work harder
and
[Music]
essentially a very kind of simple
example uh where this kind of
discussion from the couple last slides
wouldn't apply
is if the treated assignment isn't
random but
is actually associated with confounders
so let's just consider a very simple
example
you want to understand the effect of
some
um treatment that helps
mitigate and prevent obesity on quality
adjusted life years
but you didn't assign this treatment in
a randomized trials rather
you just have data from electronic
medical records
with decisions made by doctors
they saw uh fit and
here you might assume that
look doctors aren't gonna sign the
treatment kind of uniformly and random
they're gonna prioritize this treatment
to people
who have higher weight coming in
and if this is what's going on then
just taking a difference in means can
fail
to give you a valid notion of an average
treatment effect
um so kind of let's consider an extreme
example let's suppose the treatment does
nothing
so for every unit the treated and
potential
control potential outcomes are just the
same
but um here you see kind of
uh people vary by weight they vary by
outcome
there's your negative association and
what is the only effect that's going on
here is essentially that doctors are
more likely to assign treatment
um to people with higher weight than
with lower weight
and what's going to happen here well you
can have some treated units
that live in the higher weight region
controls who live here in the lower
plate region
so kind of the treatment does nothing
but if we
start looking at a difference in means
type estimator we look at the average
outcome for treated units versus
controls
what are we going to get well the
average outcome
for the treated units here for the
control units
here is higher than for the treated
units this is just a function of doctors
choosing to treat
different people how based on weight and
there being
um negative association between outcomes
and weight
um and when you put these two things
together you see that actually the
average outcome for treated units
is going to be lower than the average
outcome for the controllages units
so if you just kind of naively study
this as a randomized trial
you'd think that the treatment here was
harmful uh
whereas actually it does nothing you
just had
a selection bias issue
and you're kind of detecting that bias
so this is the end of the first part in
the second part
we're going to start talking about
conceptual and statistical solutions
for estimating average treatment effects
when you're not in a randomized trial